mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
there are three hats and each hat has an
accompanying statement
hat one the cat is in this
hat hat two the cat is
not in this hat hat three
the cat is not in hat one
exactly one of the statements is true
and exactly one hat
contains a cat which hat
contains the cat is it hat 1
hat 2 hat 3 none of the hats
or there is not enough information
a survey for a similar problem found
only 36
percent of people selected the correct
answer
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will solve the problem by logically
considering each case
suppose the cat is in hat 1
we will then evaluate each statement
since the cat is in hat 1 the first
statement will be true
similarly since the cat is in hat 1 it
will not be in hat 2
which means the statement for hat 2 will
also be true
the statement on the third hat will not
be true it will be false
but now we have two statements that are
true and that contradicts
the given information that exactly one
of the statements is true
therefore we cannot have the cat in hat
one
this cannot be the correct answer let's
now suppose the cat is in hat three
we will evaluate each of the statements
the first statement will be false
the second statement will be true but
the third statement will also be true
once again we have two statements that
are true which means this cannot be the
answer
we finally consider if the cat was in
hat2
in that case the first statement will be
false
the second statement will also be false
and the third statement
well this statement will be true because
the cat is not in hat one
therefore we have exactly one statement
that's true
this case is therefore the answer the
answer is
b the cat is in hat too
and i think what confuses a lot of
people is that hat two
has a statement that the cat is not in
that hat
however when you work through the
possibilities this is the only logical
case
that works out did you figure it out
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels
on youtube see you next episode and join
our quest
to solve the world's problems one video
at a time
[Music]